OTHER NEWS. I WANT TT
TOO WHILE I HAVU  OFF AND
WE GALK. IE
SEGMENTH ARREST OF A JOURNALGAAG
MO THE COLDATION? AND HOWTERESP
AN AMER JOURNAL
DRGETA IN
RUSSIAR WHETHERWA TDOWNING ONEFP
WI WRE NOT GOING TO PUT UPTH BUN
REPORTERS WHO VANISHED, LOST
A DEAFENING MESSAGE TO RUSSIA.
UHOT ABO4 HOURS
TO RELEASE THA REPORR.EAL
EQ IN TATNS GOI'R
READY OS IN
TH OFNUTS  DIPTI
DIPLOMATSONENDING
THIS REALSEQUENCES
BEYOND THAT, IN
NS, WE JUST,
KNVE BEENE D HOUT MY CAREER. THT
JOLEASED IN THE4SO IFIDTATES RI,
OU SAY REAL
FOR THE RUNS WHAT YOU WOUMA
DAYS OF OURION WHEN
WAS IMPLICATED IN INIDENT G
BRITAINK WEABOUT 40 DIPLOMATSOPN
COTRID THE SAME. THISTHIS IS THE
YOU HAVE TO PUT YOUR
UNDERS THE CONSEQUENCES WITH
THISD OF PROVOCATION. I
DON'T WANT TO LE THE OFAN FRE AE
TEENPONSE BYS  ORTERNATIONAL BY
SLOWETR IT'S THE CHINESE
AN THEY CAN'T MOVE SLOA DRONE
ND UP. UH OF AMERICAN
JOURNALISTS T THEIR JOB,PECIALL,
FLORIDA'S REPUBLICA G,
IS DOING SOME
AS HE  CALLING A DISU'R IN UK
ROOM IN THE
PU PARTYLOGISTS
OF PUTIN LK, WITH HIS ASSERTIONL
COMMENT MONTHS AGO,
TH STAND BY MOREBOUT INHEDA, MEL
EQUINC RUSSIA AND
. I ME ISN'T A
MORALIS IS THEIAN INVASION AS TE
WITH THE SUPPORT THEY NEEDUSSI.
THAT'S WHAT WE DID BACK IN THE
AN ERA. THE REAGATRINE
. ICALLY SAID IYOLLING TOILMES ,
SOVE THEM
TO BE A VERYG VOICHA,HEUKRAINE.R
FIGHT ANYBOINMIR P
OUGHT.WOLF H. THEYNTINUE TO BEE
TO GIVE THE PLANS.IL, WLL A. ITT
LONG. WHERE THE LEADER OF T
SORS THEED. THEY TRS,  THEAI
IDINTERNATIONAL BODEWIFE AND IVE
UKRA A MONTH AFTER
FUGEE CENTER. I
HAVE TO WOLF, I WILL
EY, THE FEAR LOOKSS OF T OF EVEE